larry david is a genius he is a genius
he just won a lifetime
yeah he's a genius he really was the
brains behind seinfeld right [ __ ] a
yeah by the way larry david's been a
friend of yours for over whatever
i remember when i was 12. you were at
summer camp with larry hated him never
saw him again until i became a comic
became best friends
i i was probably starting i was probably
drunk already
right i stared at him i went there's
something about you that's spooking the
[ __ ] out of me
right and he got scared because he
wasn't a drinker
he wasn't a druggie at all why did you
hate him at 12. because he was a [ __ ]
prick he was a prick yes so was i why
was he a prick what did he do to you
he was a gangly obnoxious [ __ ]
[ __ ] like i was
he used to punch me i punched him i used
to being him we had fist fights
but when i became a comic he loved my
work and i loved his work and then one
day i got drunk
at two in the morning here in new york
right and i and something about him
scared the [ __ ] out of me and we
retraced our childhood i went i went to
this [ __ ] camp when i was 12 i said i
went to camp
which game was that i kept all america i
went how about the camp
you're that [ __ ] [ __ ] and we came
to blows at the bar
you beat them up well we we grabbed each
other by our sweaters so
listen this about four months ago right
i rarely see him right the guy loves me
i got his back he's got mine but
sometimes you just you you
you're just doing your own thing you do
your own thing i don't give a [ __ ] right
i love the guy though
so he goes he says meet me at this
restaurant in beverly hills it was a
real posh place
that's all right i've been there you
know i didn't give a [ __ ] but he
i don't like him pain all the time right
so i i mean i got bread
but he's loaded obviously right hundreds
of people half hour early
right i knew the guy made you just say
listen bring me the check
and they get nervous i don't know mr j
no no [ __ ] mr david i'm paying for the
dinner
right he comes a half hour late
the maitre d comes over and and i start
i look at the menu
and larry says don't don't embarrass me
what do you mean embarrass you just
he brings us the food that he wants us
to eat this was just [ __ ]
put my pappy on yeah i wonder what the
[ __ ] i want
he doesn't believe in ordering no he
says because they know they let him let
the chef
bring us food wow i mean this is so
unlikely because he's a real
down-to-earth guy
right the guy brings about 25 [ __ ]
entrees
now i'm thinking i'm in i'm in for like
a thousand dollars already right
the phone rings in 20 seconds he's a
half hour late
the phone rings at 20 seconds right it's
steve martin i'm sorry for name dropping
all right
and he's part of the famous club he says
see what's wrong
holy [ __ ] i forgot he closes his cell
phone
he says i have a poker game it's i i
forgot
and he left and he left you sitting here
you're stuck with the stuck with 30
dishes in a thousand dollar bill